[Música]
todos nós sabemos da importância que tem
a empresa a nossa comunidade
o que seria da nossa comunidade sem a
nossa grande briga e a gente pensa
sempre uma maneira que essa empresa
tenha uma longevidade para que essa
comunidade que tem todo o redor possa
perdurar o tempo e como a gente tem essa
longevidade
há diferentes maneiras normalmente a
gente vê a empresa do lado de fora dos
seus mundos por suas certo ea gente às
vezes imagina o que está fazendo lá
dentro é muito comum a gente pensar
produzir ó produz as elétricos produz
aços especiais nas coisas lá dentro do
que apenas a produção e eu vou falar que
aqui atrás desses muros têm pesquisa em
ciência e inovação como fator para
garantir essa longevidade da empresa mas
a forma de eu falar vai ser uma forma
muito pessoal
eu tô funcional foi aqui como obrigada a
pesquisa
então como que começou essa história
então eu quando era pequeno
lá em lima duarte que uma cidade pequena
perto de juiz de fora
eu sempre tive o sonho de ser um
cientista alguém que transforma as
coisas e longo do mesmo estúdio eu fiz
técnico em metalurgia e foi através da
metodologia que eu cheguei na empresa em
1985 e foi trabalhando com todo o
processo de nox em conta os processos de
notas então na época a empresa empresa
estatal não tinha um centro de pesquisa
como fazer pesquisa na época tinha
interna
um grupo da metalurgia que existe até
hoje mas que eles iam fazer a pesquisa
dentro do ambiente industrial
então aquele teste de um assunto novo
era uma corrida de 80 por ela
os testes eram próprios equipamentos
então o risco é muito maior o risco de
dar um problema de parar a produção eu
tenho que ser tudo muito bem pensado
a margem de erro é muito pequena e como
reduzir o risco um conhecimento às
pessoas que trabalhavam aqui algumas os
engenheiros em geral com mestrado tinha
muito conhecimento e ao mesmo tempo não
só conhecimento mas o trabalho em equipe
compartilhando conhecimento para a
minimização de risco e o controle do
processo onde trabalhava trabalhava
muito que se essa equipe de metereologia
eram contra o processo de nox e eu via
aquele trabalho que comecei a trabalhar
com nox e eu comecei agora essas duas
coisas material enquanto que tinha de
versatilidade utilidade e eu pensei
assim pô
estou querendo trabalhar com esse tipo
de material da forma mais aprofundada
eu queria ainda no meu sonho trabalhar
com pesquisa como fazer isso então não
tinha que estudar então fiz engenharia
mecânica na época na puc que hoje é o
unileste engenharia mecânica que não
tinha metalúrgica que a mecânica que era
próximo do meu curso depois ao terminar
falei assim não para ser realmente um
pesquisador que era o meu sonho eu
preciso estudar mais
então resolvi fazer o mestrado mestrado
eu fui fazer a prova do mestrado fifa
são carlos na verdade federal no curso
de engenharia de materiais os mais
reputados da época e para fazer o curso
eu vou sair da empresa e vou para lá mas
eu recebi um convite para fazer pela
empresa e eu entrei dentro de um
programa que é um dos programas mais
bonitos que eu acho que a formação de
pessoas da empresa que é a um apoio para
mestrados e doutorados fazendo mestrado
eu fiquei um ano lá em seu carro conta
da empresa depois tive condições de
fazer todos os testes para a conclusão
do mestrado
o apoio é muito grande então hoje a
empresa tem mais de 100 pessoas formadas
desse jeito hoje o presidente e
diretores têm mestrado em função desse
programa valorização de conhecimento
já naquela época e ao retornar à empresa
tinha sido privatizado
somente naquela época tem toda aquela
condição inicial de mudanças com relação
à necessidade de adequar ao mundo real
tem que dar lucro e ela se organizou
poucos anos depois de viver com idade de
se fazer investimentos em pesquisa criou
se então centro de pesquisa
logo em seguida a última oportunidade de
e para o centro de pesquisa e dentro da
saída para o centro de pesquisas nós
começamos a trabalhar naquela época na
década de 90 justamente na parte de
lotes sempre trabalhando com inox é
descobrir essa essa vocação do brasil
a vocação da do que poderia usar o inox
no brasil então aqui uma aplicação a
figura mostra bastante uma diferença de
um laço comum de inox no sistema de
esmagamento da entrada da usina de
produção de açúcar real
a corrosão que acontece no nosso carbono
ela deixa libera produtos para o açúcar
e que ele perdia preço por isso então
muito dessa o início do processo
produtivo não significa açúcar nos
possamos colocar de princípios de nox
não só isso a gente percebeu que o
processo como um todo algo muito brasil
tinha tudo para ser desenvolvido
desenvolvemos então mundo do uso de
notas em diferentes partes diferentes
assuntos
tudo com muito conhecimento para
conseguir desenvolver e ampliar o
mercado para isso o uso do inox
nesse tipo de indústria é um
desenvolvimento brasileiro bastante nós
então ao conseguir comprada a gente
começou a pensar sim uma empresa
estrangeira vai acabar com a pesquisa
porque ele tem pesquisa no matriz e vão
deixar a pesquisadora matei
então aquela dúvida aconteceu o
contrário
chegaram com a filosofia de que a
empresa a pesquisa é algo que transforma
as empresas então triplicamos a área
construída
a quantidade de pessoas comprando os
equipamentos mais modernos foi uma época
bastante expansão e de oportunidades e
nessa época eu estava pensando em
estudar um pouco mais fazer o doutorado
e ao mesmo tempo combinado com algo do
exterior para vivenciar uma outra
cultura aproveitar essa interação que
seria boa a frança houve a oportunidade
de fazer um doutorado na escola de
meninas de 7 e uma escola também de
muita reputação
fui para lá com a minha esposa ela a
escola tinha muitos equipamentos muito
bons bons professores
então aprendi a trabalhar com esses
equipamentos bastante modernos e
aprendemos muito no país também não vê
gente voltou com um filho que nasceu na
frança e trazendo esse lado de o quanto
que um país organizado existe o respeito
pelo cidadão com muita admiração pela
parte do doutorado e o que eu fui ver
principalmente lá eu vi que apesar de
excelentes equipamentos o que fazia
diferença eram as pessoas são as pessoas
que conseguem transformar estes
resultados para alguma coisa real não é
o equipamento que tal resultado
a transformação do conhecimento em algo
útil encostar através das pessoas
e foi justamente através desses
conhecimentos novos que eu pude aprender
que quando eu voltei eu comecei a
trabalhar com alguns tipos de materiais
aços inoxidáveis e ritmos que na época
tinham os problemas de superfície eram
grandes desafios e nestes desafios
a gente usou muito das características
que tem na nossa empresa
alguns aqui pra empresa são equipamentos
que não dão muita produtividade dentro
daquela visão de pessoas não da
produtividade mas será que dá algum tipo
de transformação
o metalúrgico é diferente então usando
alguns conhecimentos aprofundados nós
conseguiram tirar algumas propriedades
únicas e desenvolver nos acessos e no
mundo normalmente são usados aços na
fabricação de algumas baixas elas as que
usam níquel são mais caros
desenvolvemos as us 100 mil mais barato
únicos e que nós consideramos de padrão
um mundial já foi o uso do conhecimento
mas ao mesmo tempo todo lado
ligado à ao uso do que entende o que tem
na empresa usar o recurso disponível não
achar que aquele recurso só tem um lado
ruim tem um lado bom mas a gente vê que
tudo tem muito ciclo então um ciclo de
a gente viu que teve a crise é uma
produção normal caiu e nós vimos que a
gente precisava fazer algo diferente o
que precisava na época desenvolver no
mercado de notas
então nós vimos que a gente podia
desenvolver as do setor de óleo e gás
estava começando a ter o bumbum do
pré-sal e nós resolvemos fazer o aço do
play off que é o aço que ao retirar o
petróleo do fundo do mar
a parte que tem contato com o petróleo é
justamente o aço inoxidável do pleito
têm alta resistência mecânica alta
resistência à corrosão e é justamente
por isso que ele é um aço excelente para
essa aplicação mas para produzir é muito
difícil da aciaria ao corte final temos
que desenvolver diferentes processos
para isso porque o duplex é o ápice da
tecnologia inox detalhes fazem a
diferença
internamente nós temos que vencer muita
muita resistência em terra
esse aço em alguns equipamentos os
operadores chamam é o pitbull
dificuldade para segurar o equipamento
vai sair quebrando tudo
então mas nós conseguimos desenvolver
hoje é um aço
e tem uma aceitação muito grande dos
clientes nós superamos um desafio
tecnológico que para muitos na época era
algo que a gente não conseguiria fazer e
há pouco tempo atrás eu assumia a a
gerência da pesquisa e na gerência da
pesquisa eu me deparei com alguns outros
desafios então antes muito ligado ao
inox agora também ligar pau um
magnetismo dos atos elétrons e algo
sutil a empresa também e uma coisa é ser
pesquisador você levará as pesquisas no
final coisa é você auxiliar e inspirar
os outros a fazer pesquisa a querer dar
o máximo e é muito recompensador também
vê quando as pessoas estão conseguindo
fazer isso e um gerente tem também a
função de criar uma estrutura que seja
adequada
eu que sou da área acaba facilitando e
isso em termos de equipamentos nas
pessoas com as coisas estão funcionando
e ao mesmo tempo a gente tem que cuidar
desse futuro que lá atrás quando eu
estudei outros têm que passar também
estimular as pessoas a fazer estudos
avançados sejam mestrados e doutorados
para estimular as pessoas a participarem
de eventos externos porque pra ver o
conhecimento que aconteceu lá fora e
trazer para mostrar o que a gente tem
também isso desenvolve muito e nós
fizemos muitas parcerias parceria com a
ufmg o photoshop unicamp ufrj o ime
instituto militar de engenharia e aqui é
apenas um exemplo de que essas parcerias
não são apenas de uma direção mas é de
mão dupla
nós recebemos recente o título de amigo
do im o que tem pessoas de lá que vêm
aqui para estudar fazer alguns
experimentos nós mandamos materiais e
essas essas parcerias são importantes
para nós porque nós não somos uma ilha e
nós não sabemos tudo
nós temos boas pessoas que temos que ter
com as pessoas a fazer essa paz e esse
conhecimento
mas a gente precisa e para fora também e
recente também o que aconteceu o desafio
que a gente precisava ter uma dinâmica
maior de maior rapidez nas nossas nossas
pesquisas chegarem ao mercado e ao mesmo
tempo no brasil a nós
o ele tem um mercado pela maioria do
consumo baixo precisava aumentar mas
como o que fazer fica parecendo que tem
alguma coisa ea gente poderia fazer com
a bola fora muitas a mas aí vem algo que
eu chamo de senso de observação que tem
é uma característica de um pesquisador
que é muito importante aqui é uma
aplicação recente e foi descoberta com
relação a um caminhão betoneira
um caminhão betoneira sempre feito com o
assunto comum se percebeu que se usando
algum assunto e nós ou o time se poderia
ter uma durabilidade três a quatro vezes
maior e isso não foi ao acaso e uma
pessoa daqui ficou fazendo doutorado em
uberlândia a partir de desgaste e se
percebeu isso e até o centro de
observação para conseguir ver uma
aplicação opa o inox pode ser útil nessa
condição
pegar o lado técnico e transformar uma
realidade aplicada
e isso não só para um lado do concreto
não foi usado também para o aceno de
mina menina de agricultura e nós
começamos a perceber que no brasil nós
temos setores muito muitas
possibilidades
nossa agricultura é fantástica é um
setor do café setor da soja tem muita
coisa que a gente pode usar o aço
correto desde que tenham conhecimento
desde que o pesquisador faça o teste
específico para conseguir fazer essa
utilização
então é a tradução de um conhecimento
para algo que vai ser aplicado sem tem
esse conhecimento não se tem didática
então é a formação das pessoas
é essa condição e um outro exemplo de
desafio
ele veio no desafio da dos aços
elétricos de grande entado que são
utilizados em transformadores
o mercado já exigia que se tivesse uma
eficiência energética maior eficiência
energética
vamos imaginar uma onde a gente vai
comprar uma geladeira ele padrão a alta
eficiência o é baixo não tem menos
perdas por aquecimento outras perdas que
acontece na passagem da corrente dos
transformadores que pegam a aquela
energia que chega que vem das
hidrelétricas e chega até nossa casa
então apenas transmissões a mais 10 mil
volts em chegar à nossa casa 110 220 não
ter uma alta eficiência e o nosso
material já está ficando ultrapassado
então o pesquisador de persistência de
fazer testes uma nova tecnologia no
forno bem rudimentar que a gente fala aí
a gente poderia falar e que depois
vendas conseguidas
fizemos um intercâmbio com o instituto
italiano nós construímos uma linha
piloto dentro do laboratório
investimento de três milhões de reais ao
alto para uma um laboratório de pesquisa
deu certo vamos em frente
foi feito um investimento de 70 milhões
na usina para implantar tecnologia e que
é um mês
o processo foi completamente encerrado o
processo antigo foi paralisado e agora
temos um outro processo a seus melhores
e além disso um processo que a gente vê
uma perspectiva de nos próximos 10 a 15
anos no mínimo
teremos novos assuntos que irão então é
dentro dessa possibilidade de é uma
construção que vem com o tempo
o projeto começou há 10 anos e tem novos
projetos em projetos para carros
híbridos
nós temos um assunto que
experimentalmente dão muito certo não se
esperando algumas investimentos
industriais pra conseguir implantar aço
inox para aplicações como biogás
indústria nova
anual de segunda geração então tem tem
coisas acontecer justifica a gente
pensar se nós continuarmos investindo
nas pessoas na capacitação valorizando o
conhecimento
nós vamos continuar tendo uma
longevidade da empresa
ao mesmo tempo eu falo que eu já passei
por muita coisa dentro da empresa
eu consegui vencer um sonho aquele
menino que queria viver o lado da
pesquisa e que pra mim é muito bom ter
uma empresa que tem condições disso num
ao mesmo tempo eu falo que vou passar o
gerente vai passar o pesquisador fica
aqui é uma forma de ser e eu espero
sempre que a empresa continua se
dedicando tempo as pessoas a formação
das pessoas para que a gente tenha essa
empresa de forma duradoura e encerrando
a palestra gosto eu tenho e não falar
para todos que vocês olharem do lado de
fora da empresa
vocês podem ter certeza que essa empresa
tem pesquisa tem futuro e que mesmo
sendo uma cidadezinha do interior de
minas
aqui tem esse tipo de padrão em
[Aplausos]
[Música]